Angela Bassett did the thing and Ariana
Dubose Twitter account went missing
after her bafta Awards rap backfired
online awesome ladies in the room
supporting and leading all here I
presume let's rewind
on Sunday the actress opened the British
Academy film Awards the UK's version of
the Oscars with a medley of sisters are
doing it for themselves We are family
and an original rap which shouted out
all the female nominees
Viola Davis
okay you're a genius Jamie Lee you are
all of us and while Jamie Lee Curtis was
totally into it it's an extraordinary
moment people weren't feeling it online
in fact the comments were so harsh
Ariana deactivated her Twitter account
now one of the events producers Nick
Bolin is coming to the Oscar winners
defense calling the backlash incredibly
unfair in a statement to variety after
the show Nick said Ariana's performance
had people clapping and dancing the vibe
was good
foreign
Nick pointed out that it was a great
year for women in film and they wanted
to celebrate that look at you you're
just literally the embodiment of like
female empowerment thank you I
appreciate it I mean that's what we got
to do out here Nick stressed that Ariana
worked with a great musical director and
choreographer but he says a lot of
people don't like change and the bath
does have historically been slightly
stiff while American shows have more
Razzmatazz there will be dancing there
will be singing quote we felt we're not
about Revolution we're about Evolution
let's just evolve
[Applause]
get up everybody and while Ariana has
not publicly addressed the performance
she did share a few snaps from the show
on Instagram Tuesday Morning writing
some moments I loved with people I love
so the trolls may have come for Ariana
online but she has plenty of positive
things to keep her mind off the hate
last year she won the best supporting
actress Oscar for her role as Anita in
West Side Story you think I want to stay
here in the City full of ugly little
animals like you
no Gracia it's a very cool thing you
know when you see your name in I don't
know some article and like it starts
with that it's attached now she's
joining the MCU playing Calypso in
Marvel's Craven the Hunter
excited by it JC chandor is our director
on that film and I love him I believe in
him and I think he's going to do
something very cool with these
characters and um
you know a little bit of superhero never
hurt anybody so to paraphrase Ariana at
the bath does
the thing she's also doing the thing
[Music]